you know we're told that
uh glenn young can win one because of
racism and there are a lot of uh
white suprema all these all these
parents
a bunch of white supremacists and that's
why they voted for glenn young
because this this is a this is a
strategy that's really going to work
going into 2022 the midterms going and
then going into 2024.
i mean the democrats they tried calling
parents domestic terrorists
terry mcauliffe came out and said uh
parents it's none of your business what
happens in the schools
let the teachers decide
major backlash against that
and uh now they're simply going to
double down on it and say yeah you're a
bunch of racist white supremacists but
that's interesting because the
lieutenant governor
is a woman by the name of winsome sears
and she's a black woman
she's the first black lieutenant
governor in virginia
and this is the woman that a bunch of
white supremacist racists voted for
now she got up last night to speak and
um all those racists in the audience
they were you know oddly enough i don't
know if they all had their eyes closed
or what it was kind of dark you know i i
don't know what it is
they didn't notice that she was a black
woman because they're all cheering for
her even though they're a bunch of races
but um let's listen to a little bit of
uh winsome sears last night
we're going to have safer neighborhoods
safer communities
and our children are going to get a good
education
because education lifted my father out
of poverty education lifted me out of
poverty education will lift us all out
of poverty because we
we must have marketable skills so that
our children cannot just survive but
they will thrive and they will create
generational wealth
that's what this is about
[Applause]
i'm going to finish up
we love you too
it's a historic night yes it is but i
didn't run to make history i just wanted
to leave it better than i found it
you know she is actually a talented and
charismatic speaker
and there aren't very many of those in
the republican party um there aren't
many very many of those in politics
general or in life it's that's a it's a
rare it's a rare talent
but the republican party has been has
been really hurting for those for those
types of um politicians who can get up
there and just kind of speak and sound
natural not sound scripted and have a j
have a have a natural kind of charisma
to she really has that so i think
there's a star in the making here we'll
be seeing a lot more from winsome seers
uh who again is
beloved by the white supremacists in the
audience cheering
shouting they love her
how could that be well you know here's
how it really happens is because uh the
media when the media gets around to
acknowledging the existence of winsome
sears which they haven't done
they just they right now the strategy is
we're not going to talk about this woman
at all
um
but eventually especially if she gets
more and more high-profile
um
they're going to have to acknowledge her
and when they do they're going to say
well she is uh
she's technically black but really she's
a part of the
she's a part of the structures of
whiteness or whatever nonsense
so she's she's white in spirit
if not in terms of skin pigment that's
what they'll say
now all that said
of course making this a racial thing is
absurd
and it would be absurd no matter what
especially absurd when the guy who lost
is white
um as well
but making this a racial thing is absurd
saying that it's uh you know tying this
to racism is of course completely
ridiculous
this is part of the democrat tourette
syndrome they don't it's this just it's
instinctive everything anytime something
doesn't go the way they like there's
racism racism
um they can't you know they're stuck in
traffic and they're in their cars
shouting racism racism did this
that's all ridiculous
however
the claim that part of the story here is
quote unquote white backlash
um that's not entirely falls
you know there is an element of
so-called white backlash in that
it turns out
white parents
aren't really crazy about sending their
kids to school
so that they can learn that um they are
evil that they're inherently bigoted
that they are the inheritors of
generational guilt for things that they
didn't do
okay so yeah it turns out white people
aren't a lot of white people aren't
crazy about that
it turns out that a lot of white people
don't like being cast as the villains
don't like being degraded and insulted
so is that part of the story sure that's
part of it
and there's there's nothing
strange about that there's nothing
outrageous about it there's certainly
nothing racist about
it from the left perspective you know
they think
they should be able to shout at white
people say you're all a bunch of
scumbags and villains
and say you know send your kids to us
and we're going to tell them the same
thing
send your send your your your scummy
demon offsprings to us
so we can tell them all about how
they're inherently racist and that
nobody can be racist against them
um
and that's somehow they have to
apologize simply for existing
all of their you know
their ancestors were all
scumbags as well or worse
so the left thinks they should tell that
they should say that to us and our
response should be okay yes yes sir
yes ma'am however you identify
and we bow our heads in shame and go
along and if and if we dare say you know
what i'm not no i'm not crazy about that
i don't agree
then they start shouting white backlash
the white people are upset
well yeah
yes
you're correct about that part of it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content